- Selamat datang kembali di "Memahami Informasi dan
Komputasi Kuantum." Nama saya John Watrous, dan saya adalah Direktur Teknis
untuk IBM Quantum Education.
Ini adalah pelajaran kelima dari seri ini, dan merupakan pelajaran pertama di
unit kedua seri ini, yang membahas tentang Algoritma Kuantum.
Di unit ini, kita akan menelusuri
keunggulan komputasional dari informasi kuantum, artinya, kita akan
melihat apa yang bisa kita lakukan
dengan komputer kuantum dan keunggulan yang mungkin dimiliki komputer kuantum
dibandingkan komputer klasik.
Kita akan fokus pada apa yang bisa dilakukan dengan satu komputer kuantum, bukan dalam pengaturan terdistribusi,
misalnya,
di mana beberapa komputer kuantum berinteraksi melalui jaringan tertentu.
Memang ada keunggulan kuantum yang bisa ditemukan dalam pengaturan terdistribusi, di mana komunikasi dan
kriptografi ikut berperan,
tapi kita tidak akan
membahas hal-hal itu di unit ini.
Unit ini membahas algoritma kuantum yang berjalan pada satu komputer kuantum.
Mari kita mulai dengan pertanyaan yang wajar. Keunggulan apa yang mungkin bisa ditawarkan
komputer kuantum?
Yang utama adalah komputer kuantum mungkin bisa memberikan solusi lebih cepat untuk beberapa masalah komputasional.
Waktu itu berharga, dan meski komputer yang kita
pakai sehari-hari cukup cepat, mereka masih terlalu lambat
untuk memecahkan masalah komputasional tertentu karena memang
kesulitan komputasional yang melekat pada masalah-masalah itu.
Potensi komputer kuantum yang mungkin memungkinkan kita memecahkan masalah yang terlalu lambat
untuk diselesaikan oleh komputer klasik
inilah yang benar-benar mendorong
penelitian algoritma kuantum selama beberapa dekade terakhir.
Ada sumber daya komputasional lain selain waktu yang bisa dipertimbangkan, seperti jumlah memori komputer yang dibutuhkan untuk komputasi,
tapi komputer kuantum tidak bisa
menawarkan penghematan yang banyak dalam hal memori, ternyata, dan memori komputer
klasik cukup murah
terutama dibandingkan dengan memori kuantum. Jadi memang tidak ada
banyak harapan di sini.
Kita juga bisa memikirkan sumber daya lain seperti jumlah energi
yang dibutuhkan untuk komputasi, tapi sebenarnya kamu tidak
butuh banyak energi sama sekali
untuk komputasi klasik, terutama kalau kamu
mau memperlambat prosesnya.
Jadi memang waktu
yang dibutuhkan untuk komputasilah yang menjadi fokus utama kita.
Berikut ini gambaran umum pelajaran ini, yang membahas tentang
model komputasi yang dikenal sebagai model query.
Kamu bisa menganggap model ini seperti cawan Petri untuk mengembangkan ide-ide algoritmik, baik kuantum maupun klasik.
Ini bukan model praktis yang menggambarkan jenis
masalah komputasional yang kita hadapi di kehidupan nyata.
Kita akan meninggalkan model query di pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya di unit ini dan beralih ke model yang lebih termotivasi oleh
konsep komputasi yang lebih praktis,
tapi model query adalah
tempat yang sangat bagus untuk memulai.
Ini model yang sederhana yang memungkinkan kita mengeksplorasi
potensi komputer kuantum tanpa banyak detail teknis yang menghalangi,
dan juga memungkinkan kita untuk mengisolasi beberapa
ide terpenting di balik komputasi kuantum dan cara kerjanya.
Komputasi kuantum memang pertama kali berkembang dalam model ini, dan ide-ide yang
dikembangkan di dalamnya secara langsung menginspirasi
algoritma kuantum penting
seperti algoritma Shor untuk faktorisasi.
Di bagian pertama pelajaran ini, kita akan melihat secara spesifik apa itu model komputasi query,
dan di bagian kedua, ketiga,
dan keempat, kita akan membahas tiga
algoritma query kuantum, yaitu algoritma Deutsch,
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa,
dan algoritma Simon, yang mengungkapkan keunggulan yang semakin
mengesankan
dari komputer kuantum
dibandingkan komputer klasik dalam model komputasi query.
Untuk menjelaskan model komputasi query, mari kita mulai dengan abstraksi
komputasi yang lebih standar.
Berikut gambar yang
merepresentasikan komputasi dalam istilah yang sangat sederhana dan mendasar.
Kita punya input, yang biasanya berbentuk
string biner, meski kita bisa menggunakan simbol lain kalau mau.
Input diberikan ke komputasi, yang direpresentasikan oleh
persegi panjang biru di gambar ini,
dan hasil komputasinya adalah dihasilkannya suatu output, dan lagi-lagi, itu biasanya
berupa string biner.
Tentu saja, gambar ini
sama sekali tidak spesifik tentang bagaimana komputasi itu sendiri bekerja.
Kita bisa merumuskan
model komputasional spesifik yang berbeda untuk itu, seperti mesin Turing
dan Boolean circuit,
atau quantum circuit kalau kita memikirkan tentang
komputasi kuantum.
Memang benar bahwa gambar ini
tidak merepresentasikan fakta bahwa banyak
komputer yang kita gunakan sehari-hari terus-menerus menerima
input dan menghasilkan output,
pada dasarnya berinteraksi dengan kita dan dengan komputer lain melalui
internet, misalnya.
Tapi kita tidak mencoba merepresentasikan
interaksi-interaksi itu di sini.
Ini tentang pemodelan
tugas komputasional yang terisolasi.
Misalnya, input bisa berupa
encoding biner dari sebuah angka atau representasi dari sebuah matriks
WEBVTT
atau deskripsi sebuah molekul atau apa pun yang kita pikirkan, dan ada beberapa tugas komputasional
yang dilakukan hanya pada input tersebut.
Poin utamanya adalah
bahwa seluruh input diberikan ke komputasi, dan tidak ada
informasi tentang input yang disembunyikan.
Model query
dari komputasi bekerja secara berbeda.
Dalam model query, input tersedia
dalam bentuk fungsi yang bisa diakses oleh komputasi dengan melakukan query,
atau dengan kata lain, dengan mengevaluasi fungsi
pada input yang berbeda-beda.
Di sini kamu bisa melihat representasinya
dalam bentuk gambar.
Mirip dengan yang kita lihat sebelumnya, komputasi direpresentasikan
oleh persegi panjang biru, tapi alih-alih menerima input secara langsung
dalam bentuk string
bit, misalnya, ia mengakses input dengan efektif mengajukan pertanyaan
dan mendapatkan jawaban.
Kita kadang menggunakan istilah
oracle dan black box untuk merujuk pada mekanisme
yang menyediakan input.
Ada perbedaan antara
oracle dan black box dalam teori kompleksitas, tapi itu sama sekali tidak relevan untuk keperluan diskusi ini.
Pokoknya, istilah-istilah ini dimaksudkan
untuk menyampaikan ide dasarnya.
Di Yunani kuno, kamu
bisa pergi ke oracle, seperti Oracle di Delphi,
dan mengajukan pertanyaan penting,
dan oracle akan menjawab
pertanyaan spesifik itu, tapi dia tentu tidak akan memberitahumu semua yang dia tahu.
Dengan cara yang serupa, ketika
kita memikirkan tentang black box, kita membayangkan semacam
proses atau sistem
di mana kita bisa memilih apa yang masuk dan kita bisa melihat apa yang keluar, tapi kita tidak punya pemahaman
tentang cara kerjanya di dalam.
Dan itulah kasusnya di sini. Input ke masalah
berbentuk fungsi, dan satu-satunya yang bisa kita lakukan adalah
mengevaluasi fungsi tersebut,
tapi selain itu, kita tidak punya
pengetahuan atau pemahaman tentang cara kerjanya.
Sepanjang pelajaran ini,
kita akan memakai huruf f untuk fungsi yang
merepresentasikan input, dan kita akan berasumsi
bahwa fungsi itu selalu berbentuk
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Sigma menunjukkan alfabet biner, jadi f adalah fungsi dari string
bit ke string bit,
dan secara khusus, kita akan
mengasumsikan bahwa input ke f adalah string bit dengan panjang n, dan outputnya adalah string
bit dengan panjang m,
di mana n dan m adalah bilangan bulat positif.
Untuk masalah yang berbeda, kita akan
memiliki batasan pada n dan m, tapi dalam semua kasus, fungsi input akan
berbentuk seperti ini.
Ketika kita bilang bahwa
komputasi membuat query, maksudnya adalah fungsi f dievaluasi sekali,
yaitu, beberapa string x dengan panjang N dipilih oleh komputasi, dan string f dari x kemudian
tersedia untuknya
melalui oracle atau black box. Dan akhirnya, cara sangat sederhana untuk mengukur biaya komputasional
dari sebuah algoritma query adalah dengan menghitung berapa banyak query yang diperlukannya.
Jadi, meski memang benar
bahwa kita paling tertarik pada berapa lama komputasi berlangsung, ketika kita mempelajari model query,
kita biasanya menyederhanakan
dan hanya menghitung query, dan itulah yang akan kita lakukan dalam pelajaran ini.
Sekarang, mari kita lihat beberapa
contoh masalah query, yaitu masalah komputasional dalam model query,
dan di sini, ngomong-ngomong, saya hanya akan mendeskripsikan
masalah-masalahnya saja, dan saat ini, saya tidak akan mengatakan apa pun
tentang cara memecahkannya.
Masalah pertama adalah masalah OR.
Dalam kasus ini, input adalah fungsi
dari n bit ke 1 bit saja, jadi m sama dengan 1 untuk masalah ini,
dan output yang diperlukan untuk
masalah ini adalah 1 atau 0.
Jika ada beberapa string n bit x yang f dari x sama dengan 1, maka jawaban yang benar adalah 1,
dan jika tidak, kalau f dari x selalu
0 untuk setiap string x, maka jawaban yang benar adalah 0.
Jadi kalau kita menganggap fungsi f sebagai pemberian akses acak ke dua pangkat n bit, satu untuk setiap string n bit x,
maka yang dimintanya
adalah OR dari bit-bit tersebut, dan itulah mengapa disebut masalah OR.
Contoh lainnya adalah masalah paritas, yang mirip dengan masalah OR kecuali meminta paritas,
atau dengan kata lain, eXclusive OR dari semua nilai output satu bit
dari fungsi tersebut.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah
bahwa jawaban yang benar adalah 0 jika jumlah string n bit x yang f dari x sama dengan 1 adalah genap,
dan jawaban yang benar adalah
1 jika jumlah itu ganjil.
Contoh masalah di mana m tidak harus sama dengan 1 adalah masalah minimum.
Di sini, fungsi f berbentuk biasa, dan tidak ada batasan pada n dan m,
dan jawaban yang benar adalah nilai output
dari fungsi yang muncul pertama dalam urutan leksikografis
atau urutan kamus
dari string biner. Alternatifnya, kalau kamu mau
memikirkan string dengan panjang m sebagai merepresentasikan bilangan bulat non-negatif
dalam notasi biner,
maka jawaban yang benar
adalah nilai terkecil atau nilai minimum yang
keluar dari fungsi ini.
WEBVTT
Kadang kita juga mempertimbangkan masalah query di mana kita punya janji
pada fungsi input, atau dengan kata lain, semacam
jaminan terhadapnya,
dan kita tidak khawatir tentang fungsi yang tidak memenuhi janji itu.
Fungsi yang tidak memenuhi janji dianggap sebagai input "don't care".
Dan kita tidak bertanggung jawab atas apa yang terjadi pada input-input tersebut.
Berikut contoh masalah query dengan janji yang disebut unique search.
Ini berkaitan dengan masalah OR,
tapi berbeda.
Fungsi input memiliki bentuk yang sama
dengan masalah OR, yaitu fungsi dari
string n bit ke bit.
Kali ini, kita dijanjikan bahwa
ada tepat satu string Z yang membuat f mengevaluasi ke 1,
dengan f dari x sama dengan 0
untuk setiap string x selain z, dan output yang benar
adalah string unik z ini.
Tentu saja, ada
pilihan fungsi f yang tidak memenuhi kondisi ini, tapi kita sama sekali tidak memberikan persyaratan apa pun
pada algoritma untuk masalah ini ketika diberikan fungsi seperti itu
sebagai input.
Kita hanya peduli pada fungsi yang memenuhi janjinya.
Nah, keempat masalah yang baru saja saya sebutkan semuanya cukup natural, artinya mudah untuk menjelaskannya,
dan mudah untuk membayangkan situasi di mana kebutuhan untuk memecahkannya mungkin muncul, tapi beberapa masalah query
tidak seperti ini sama sekali.
Bahkan, terkadang kita mempertimbangkan masalah query yang sangat
dibuat-buat, di mana sulit untuk membayangkan siapa pun yang benar-benar
ingin memecahkannya.
Masalah Simon, yang akan kita
lihat nanti dalam pelajaran ini, sedikit masuk dalam kategori ini, tapi ada beberapa lainnya
yang jauh lebih buruk dalam pengertian tertentu, tapi tetap saja, mereka sebenarnya cukup penting untuk studi model query.
Kita tidak mempelajari masalah-masalah ini karena kita harus ingin
memecahkannya dalam praktik.
Cara kamu bisa memikirkannya adalah bahwa kita sedang mencari
hal-hal yang ekstrem dari berbagai jenis,
khususnya, ketika kita bekerja dalam
model cawan Petri ini, cara natural untuk mengeksplorasi
ide-ide algoritmik kuantum
adalah dengan merumuskan masalah yang sangat dibuat-buat, di mana kita bisa paling baik mengeksploitasi
kemampuan komputer kuantum.
Dan ini sebenarnya
bisa memberikan banyak pencerahan tentang bagaimana komputer kuantum
berpotensi berguna dalam pengaturan yang lebih praktis.
Kita bisa memformalkan konsep
query dengan cara yang berbeda tergantung pada model komputasional
yang kita gunakan.
Misalnya, dalam model mesin Turing
dari komputasi, yang belum kita bicarakan dan tidak akan kita bahas dalam seri ini,
ada cara tertentu untuk
memformalkan konsep query yang masuk akal untuk model itu.
Untuk model circuit, kita mendefinisikan jenis
gate khusus yang disebut query gate, dan itulah cara query
secara formal direpresentasikan.
Untuk Boolean circuit, ada cara yang sangat sederhana untuk melakukan ini, yaitu dengan membayangkan
bahwa kita punya query gate
yang mengevaluasi fungsi input secara langsung, seperti yang bisa kamu lihat di sini di layar.
Idenya adalah bahwa kita bisa
menggunakan query gate ini untuk membangun circuit yang memecahkan masalah apa pun
yang sedang kita hadapi,
dan agar bisa bekerja dengan benar, circuit-nya harus memberikan jawaban yang tepat untuk fungsi input f apa pun yang diberikan,
dengan asumsi bahwa itu memenuhi janjinya dalam kasus masalah dengan janji.
Berikut contoh sederhana
dari Boolean circuit yang memecahkan masalah
paritas ketika n sama dengan 1,
jadi fungsi input f adalah dari
1 bit ke 1 bit dalam kasus ini.
Yang dilakukan circuit ini adalah mengevaluasi fungsi
f pada input 0 dan 1 menggunakan dua query gate ini.
Kemudian menghubungkan dua nilai output yang didapat dari query gate ke Boolean circuit dari pelajaran tiga yang menghitung XOR,
yang sama saja dengan paritas.
Untuk memperjelas, dua
nilai input ini bukan input ke masalah,
maksudnya masalah paritas,
ketika kita bekerja dengan model query, input ke masalah
adalah fungsi f, dan kamu harus menganggap dua input ke circuit ini
sebagai nilai yang dikodekan keras
yang tidak pernah berubah, pada dasarnya mereka adalah bagian dari algoritma.
Kita ingin menghitung XOR dari f 0 dan f 1, jadi kita menginisialisasi dua
wire ini dengan cara ini
agar bisa berjalan. Kita telah menggunakan dua query gate
di sini, yang ini dan yang ini,
dan jadi algoritma yang direpresentasikan
oleh Boolean circuit ini membuat dua query, dan kalau kita memikirkan masalah
paritas sejenak
untuk fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, kita melihat bahwa sangat perlu bagi setiap Boolean circuit
yang memecahkan masalah ini
untuk membuat setidaknya dua query.
Jika kamu hanya membuat satu query sehingga kamu hanya tahu satu
nilai output dari fungsi f dan bukan yang lainnya, kamu sebenarnya tidak punya
informasi apa pun
tentang paritasnya, karena nilai output lainnya
bisa saja 0 atau 1, yang mengarah ke salah satu dari
dua kemungkinan solusi
untuk masalah tersebut. Jadi dalam hal jumlah
query yang dibuatnya, Boolean circuit ini sebaik yang bisa dilakukan
untuk masalah paritas
ketika n sama dengan 1.
WEBVTT
Ada satu hal lain tentang query gate yang perlu disebutkan sebelum kita melanjutkan, yaitu bahwa ketika kita merancang dan menganalisis algoritma query,
kita sama sekali tidak khawatir tentang bagaimana
query gate diimplementasikan.
Diasumsikan bahwa
query gate ini diberikan kepada kita, dan kesulitan membangunnya bukanlah urusan kita.
Kamu bisa menganggap
query gate itu sendiri sebagai input kalau mau, dan bukan pekerjaan kita untuk membuat input, kita hanya mencoba
memecahkan masalah tertentu
berdasarkan input yang ada. Tentu saja, ketika f adalah fungsi
dari satu bit ke satu bit, hanya ada empat pilihan yang mungkin,
dan akan cukup mudah
untuk mengimplementasikan salah satunya, tapi pada umumnya, untuk fungsi
dengan banyak bit input,
bisa sangat sulit untuk mengimplementasikan query gate
untuk fungsi-fungsi tersebut.
Untuk memperjelas, bukan berarti
masalah bagaimana query gate
diimplementasikan itu tidak penting, tapi lebih karena hal itu tidak dianggap
sebagai bagian dari biaya
dari sebuah algoritma query.
Ini konsisten dengan gagasan bahwa ini sebenarnya bukan tentang komputasi praktis atau benar-benar membangun circuit,
melainkan tentang bekerja dalam
kerangka teoritis yang memberitahu kita hal-hal menarik
tentang komputasi.
Kita akan punya lebih banyak yang ingin dikatakan tentang ini ketika kita membuat lompatan dari model ini ke model komputasi yang lebih standar, dan itulah yang terutama akan dibahas dalam pelajaran berikutnya,
Pelajaran 6.
Sekarang mari kita beralih perhatian
ke quantum circuit.
Untuk quantum circuit, kita akan mengubah
definisi query gate agar bersifat uniter.
Kita ingin bisa membuat
query dalam quantum circuit dan agar mereka beroperasi
secara linear pada state kuantum
sehingga kita bisa secara efektif
membuat query dalam superposisi.
Mungkin sepertinya kita sedang
memindahkan gawang, begitulah istilahnya, dengan mengubah apa yang kita maksud dengan query dibandingkan dengan apa yang baru saja
kita lihat untuk Boolean circuit,
tapi ada pembenaran untuk itu yang akan kita diskusikan lebih
detail di pelajaran berikutnya.
Untuk sekarang, ini hanya sebuah definisi.
Secara khusus,
definisinya adalah sebagai berikut, diberikan fungsi f apa pun dengan
bentuk yang sama seperti sebelumnya,
artinya fungsi yang memetakan string n bit
ke string m bit, query gate Uf bekerja pada n + m qubit
dan didefinisikan oleh
aksi yang dijelaskan di sini pada state basis standar.
Kita akan melihat gambar
yang merepresentasikan definisi ini sebentar lagi, tapi pertama, izinkan saya memperjelas notasi
yang digunakan di sini,
yaitu kapan pun kita
menggunakan simbol XOR sebagai operasi antara dua
string dengan panjang yang sama,
kita mengacu pada
eXclusive OR bitwise, dan di sini kamu bisa melihat contohnya.
Dalam definisinya, kita punya bahwa y dan f dari
x adalah string dengan panjang m, jadi string ini merepresentasikan string yang kita dapatkan
dengan meng-XOR kedua string tersebut
satu bit pada satu waktu, dan berikut diagram
yang menjelaskan bagaimana gate ini bekerja.
N qubit teratas sesuai dengan
argumen dari fungsi.
Dan ketika mereka mulai
dalam state basis standar, ket x dalam diagram ini, state basis standar itu
melewatinya tanpa berubah
dan digaungkan sebagai bagian dari output.
M qubit bawah sesuai dengan output
dari fungsi f, dan ketika mereka mulai dalam
state basis standar apa pun,
ket y dalam diagram ini, yang terjadi adalah output
dari fungsi f dari x di-XOR ke string y.
Inilah yang terjadi untuk
state basis standar, dan kalau kita ingin tahu
apa yang terjadi secara umum untuk state kuantum lain, kita
menggunakan linearitas, seperti yang selalu kita lakukan.
Alasan untuk mendefinisikan query gate seperti ini di mana kita menggaungkan input dan menggunakan bitwise XOR untuk output
adalah bahwa gate-gate ini selalu uniter untuk pilihan fungsi f apa pun.
Ini sebenarnya adalah
operasi deterministik.
Dan kalau kita mengekspresikannya sebagai matriks untuk pilihan fungsi F apa pun, kita akan mendapatkan matriks permutasi,
artinya matriks dengan satu angka 1 di setiap baris dan di setiap kolom, dan semua entri lainnya sama dengan 0.
Dan matriks permutasi
selalu uniter.
Bahkan, untuk operasi ini, kita akan mendapati bahwa operasinya
adalah inversnya sendiri, jadi Uf dagger sama dengan Uf.
Kalau yang ingin kita lakukan dengan
gate-gate ini hanyalah mengevaluasi f dari x untuk beberapa string x, itu mudah,
kita bisa set y ke
string semua-nol. Jadi ketika kita mengambil eXclusive OR bitwise dari y, kita akhirnya mendapatkan f dari x saja.
Di sini, ngomong-ngomong, kamu bisa melihat notasi yang digunakan untuk menunjukkan string semua-nol.
Terlihat seperti 0 pangkat M, tapi bukan itu artinya.
Artinya string nol
dengan panjang sama dengan M.
Ketika kita berbicara tentang
string berbeda dengan angka, eksponen biasanya berarti kita mengulang string itu
beberapa kali,
jadi ini adalah 0 yang diulang m kali.
WEBVTT
Ini hanya cara yang nyaman dan tepat untuk mendeskripsikan string ini.
Sekali lagi, ketika kita
bekerja dengan model query, kita tidak khawatir tentang bagaimana
mengimplementasikan query gate ini.
Itu masalah yang sama
yang kita punya dengan query gate untuk Boolean circuit.
Bukan tugas kita untuk menyiapkan input, kita diberi input dalam
bentuk query gate ini.
Saya ingin menunjukkan bahwa, kalau kita tahu cara
mengimplementasikan fungsi f menggunakan Boolean circuit, maka memungkinkan untuk
menerjemahkan implementasi tersebut
cukup langsung ke implementasi
quantum circuit dari Uf, dan kita akan melihat persis bagaimana
itu bekerja di pelajaran berikutnya.
Sebagai catatan sampingan, sangat mudah untuk membuat Boolean circuit
yang bekerja seperti ini, menggunakan satu
query gate klasik untuk fungsi f,
tapi itu sangat berbeda dari memiliki implementasi
quantum circuit dari gate uniter ini.
Namun, poinnya adalah bahwa
untuk algoritma query klasik, memiliki query gate yang bekerja seperti ini sebenarnya setara
dengan memiliki
query gate klasik biasa untuk f, dalam arti bahwa keduanya bisa diimplementasikan menggunakan yang satu dengan yang lain.
Di bagian pelajaran ini, kita akan membahas algoritma Deutsch, yang merupakan
algoritma query kuantum yang sangat sederhana, tapi memang ini adalah sebuah permata.
Algoritma ini berasal dari makalah tahun 1985 yang ditulis oleh David Deutsch, salah satu dari orang pertama yang mengerjakan fondasi teoretis
komputasi kuantum.
Algoritma itu sendiri merupakan bagian yang sangat kecil
dari makalah Deutsch tahun 1985, dan bahkan,
algoritma yang sekarang kita
sebut algoritma Deutsch sebenarnya adalah versi yang disempurnakan dari algoritma yang Deutsch deskripsikan.
Ini memberikan contoh yang sangat sederhana tentang bagaimana komputer kuantum bisa
menawarkan keunggulan komputasional, tapi kamu harus mulai dari suatu tempat,
dan ini benar-benar adalah percikan penting yang memulai segalanya.
Algoritma Deutsch memecahkan masalah query yang sering disebut masalah Deutsch dalam konteks komputasi kuantum,
tapi sebenarnya, itu tidak lain
adalah masalah paritas untuk fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit, yang sudah kita bicarakan.
Seperti yang sudah kita lihat, ada empat fungsi
dari satu bit ke satu bit, dan mereka dideskripsikan di sini di layar berdasarkan tabel nilainya.
Fungsi pertama dan terakhir dari
fungsi-fungsi ini adalah konstan, sedangkan dua yang di tengah seimbang dalam arti dua
nilai output yang mungkin
muncul dengan jumlah yang sama.
Untuk dua fungsi konstan,
kita melihat bahwa paritas, atau dengan kata lain, eXclusive OR dari dua output adalah 0,
dan untuk dua fungsi seimbang, paritas dari outputnya adalah 1.
Jadi cara yang setara untuk
mendeskripsikan masalah paritas dalam kasus khusus ini, di mana fungsi f mengambil
satu bit sebagai input,
atau dengan kata lain, masalah Deutsch, adalah seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Input adalah fungsi f
dari satu bit ke satu bit, dan output adalah 0 jika f konstan
dan 1 jika f seimbang.
Seperti yang sudah saya sarankan, setiap algoritma query klasik
yang memecahkan masalah ini harus membuat setidaknya dua query ke f.
Jika kamu hanya mempelajari satu dari
dua nilai output f, kamu masih tidak punya informasi sama sekali tentang paritas dari dua output.
Dan ini, ngomong-ngomong, juga benar
bahkan untuk algoritma klasik yang menggunakan keacakan.
Keacakan kadang bisa sangat berguna untuk memecahkan masalah query, dan kita akan melihat contohnya
sedikit kemudian dalam pelajaran ini,
tapi keacakan tidak membantu di sini.
Jadi algoritma kita dari sebelumnya adalah optimal di antara algoritma query klasik
untuk masalah Deutsch.
Sekarang kita akan melihat
algoritma Deutsch, yang merupakan algoritma query kuantum yang memecahkan masalah Deutsch
menggunakan satu query.
Dan berikut ini algoritmanya
yang dideskripsikan sebagai quantum circuit.
Kita punya dua qubit
yang diinisialisasi seperti yang kamu lihat di sini, dengan yang atas diinisialisasi ke ket 0 dan yang bawah diinisialisasi ke ket 1,
dan kita akan melihat mengapa kita menginisialisasi qubit-qubit ini seperti ini sebentar lagi.
Kita menjalankan gate Hadamard
pada dua qubit, memasukkannya ke query gate, menjalankan gate Hadamard
lain pada qubit teratas,
dan kemudian mengukurnya. Dan klaimnya adalah bahwa
hasil pengukurannya memberikan kita, dengan pasti, jawaban yang benar untuk masalah tersebut.
Jadi mari kita analisis
circuit langkah demi langkah untuk melihat persis bagaimana cara kerjanya.
State dari dua qubit setelah lapisan pertama gate Hadamard adalah produk tensor dari
state minus dan plus.
Hadamard di atas memetakan
state 0 ke state plus, dan Hadamard di bawah memetakan state 1 ke state minus.
Qubit teratas ada di sebelah kanan, dan qubit terbawah ada di sebelah kiri, jadi inilah state yang kita dapatkan.
Sangat penting bahwa qubit bawah berada dalam state minus, ngomong-ngomong, ini tidak akan berhasil jika kita
menginisialisasi qubit bawah
ke state 0 alih-alih state 1.
Kita akan mengekspansi state ini
setengah jalan, seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Alasan melakukan itu
belum jelas saat ini, tapi akan berguna
sebentar lagi.
Selanjutnya, mari kita pikirkan tentang
state dari dua qubit setelah query gate dilakukan.
Cara query gate
bekerja adalah dengan menghitung F pada state basis standar
dari qubit teratas dan meng-XOR nilainya
ke qubit bawah,
WEBVTT
dan di sini kita bisa melihat
hasil dari melakukan itu.
Untuk suku pertama, state basis standar
dari qubit teratas adalah 0, jadi f dari nol di-XOR
ke qubit bawah,
dan itu bekerja berdasarkan linearitas. Dan serupa untuk suku kedua, kecuali state basis standar
untuk qubit teratas adalah 1, jadi kita meng-XOR f dari 1 ke qubit bawah.
Dan pada titik ini, kita bisa
menyederhanakan ekspresi ini dengan mengamati rumus
yang bisa kamu lihat di bawah sini, yang berlaku ketika a adalah 0 atau 1.
Dan kita bisa memeriksa ini untuk kedua nilai secara terpisah.
Jika a sama dengan 0, maka
meng-XOR dengan a tidak mengubah apa pun, dan negatif 1 pangkat 0 adalah 1,
sehingga kedua sisinya sama. Dan jika a sama dengan 1, kita mendapatkan ket 1 dikurangi ket
0 ketika kita mengambil XOR,
yang merupakan negatif 1
kali ket 0 dikurangi ket 1.
Dan jika kita menggunakan rumus itu
untuk menyederhanakan state kita, di mana kita mengambil a sama dengan
f dari 0 di sebelah kiri dan a sama dengan f dari 1 di sebelah kanan,
kita mendapatkan ekspresi
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Jadi ketika kita membandingkan dua
vektor state kuantum π1 dan π2, kita melihat bahwa yang dilakukan gate Uf
secara efektif adalah menempatkan
salah satu dari dua nilai, f dari 0 atau f dari 1, ke dalam
eksponen dari negatif 1,
atau dengan kata lain, ke dalam
fase dari setiap suku.
Inilah alasan untuk
menginisialisasi qubit bawah ke 1 dan menjalankan gate Hadamard padanya untuk membuat state minus,
yang memungkinkan ini terjadi.
Ini disebut fenomena phase kickback, dan kita akan kembali membahasnya sebentar lagi untuk melihatnya dari sudut yang berbeda.
Ini cukup penting, dan kita akan melihatnya terjadi beberapa
kali lagi dalam pelajaran ini, serta dalam pelajaran-pelajaran berikutnya.
Kita sekarang bisa menyederhanakan dengan menarik
kembali state minus ke luar untuk mendapatkan ekspresi
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Sebagai catatan sampingan, agak
menarik untuk diperhatikan bahwa sebenarnya tidak ada entanglement di sini.
Kedua state ini adalah product state. Jadi, meski entanglement
sangat menarik,
kebetulan tidak memainkan
peran apa pun dalam algoritma khusus ini.
Mari kita rapikan sedikit agar kita punya ruang lebih banyak.
Yang sekarang bisa kita lakukan adalah
menarik faktor negatif 1 yang dipangkatkan f dari nol ke luar
untuk mendapatkan ekspresi
state yang kamu lihat di sini.
Kamu akan perhatikan bahwa di sini kita punya eXclusive OR dari f 0 dan f 1 di eksponen negatif 1.
Kita mungkin mengharapkan itu
menjadi f dari 1 dikurangi f dari 0 karena kita menarik faktor negatif 1 pangkat f dari 0 keluar,
tapi kita mendapatkan nilai yang sama
jika kita mengambil XOR karena ini adalah bit, dan satu-satunya hal yang penting ketika kita punya bilangan bulat di
eksponen negatif 1
adalah apakah bilangan bulat itu genap atau ganjil.
Cara lain untuk mengekspresikan
state ini adalah seperti yang kita punya di sini, di mana kita hanya mempertimbangkan
dua kasus yang mungkin untuk XOR.
dan itu adalah cara yang nyaman
untuk mengekspresikan state ketika kita mempertimbangkan aksi
dari gate Hadamard terakhir bersama dengan pengukuran.
Ketika kita menjalankan gate
Hadamard terakhir pada qubit teratas, state plus
ditransformasi menjadi state 0
dan state minus
ditransformasi menjadi state 1, yang bisa kita tulis lebih
ringkas seperti ini.
Dan akhirnya, ketika
pengukuran dilakukan, hasil yang kita dapatkan adalah
XOR dari f 0 dan f 1,
yaitu nilai yang kita cari, dan itulah cara kerja algoritma Deutsch.
Cukup sederhana, dan kalau kita bertanya pada diri sendiri apa
yang membuatnya berhasil, memungkinkan kita menghitung
paritas dua bit
dengan satu query alih-alih dua, jawaban yang masuk akal adalah
itulah interferensi.
Kita secara efektif
menghitung f dari 0 dan f dari 1 pada waktu yang sama, karena kita pertama-tama menjalankan
gate Hadamard
pada qubit teratas untuk menempatkan input ke f ke dalam
superposisi 0 dan 1.
Dan melalui phase kickback bersama dengan gate Hadamard terakhir, kita pada dasarnya menciptakan
interferensi konstruktif
untuk jawaban yang benar dan interferensi destruktif
untuk jawaban yang salah.
Jadi kita tidak melihat jawaban yang salah, kita hanya melihat jawaban yang benar.
Sekarang izinkan saya mengatakan sedikit lagi tentang fenomena phase kickback hanya untuk melihatnya dari
sudut yang sedikit berbeda.
Pertama, mari kita amati
rumus yang sangat sederhana ini di mana b dan c adalah nilai biner yang sembarang.
Singkatnya, meng-XOR bit b dengan nilai 1 adalah hal yang sama dengan menjalankan gate NOT atau operasi x pada b,
dan tentu saja, meng-XOR
bit b dengan nilai 0 tidak melakukan apa pun padanya, yang sama saja dengan menjalankan
operasi identitas padanya.
Dan kita bisa mengekspresikan operasi identitas sebagai x pangkat 0.
Jadi kalau kita menjalankan gate Uf pada dua qubit dalam state basis standar ket b tensor ket a,
kita mendapatkan hasil ini, hanya berdasarkan definisi dari gate Uf.
WEBVTT
dan menggunakan rumus tersebut, kita bisa menulis state itu secara alternatif seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Rumus ini berlaku untuk semua pilihan b, jadi berdasarkan linearitas, rumus ini berlaku
untuk state SI yang sembarang
sebagai pengganti ket b.
Dan khususnya, kalau kita mau, kita bisa memilih SI menjadi state minus.
Dan inilah kunci mengapa fenomena phase kickback
terjadi.
Itu karena operasi x
yang diterapkan pada state minus memberikan kita negatif 1 kali state minus.
Dalam istilah matematis, kita mengatakan bahwa state minus
adalah eigenvector dari operasi x, dengan eigenvalue sama dengan negatif 1.
Eigenvector dan eigenvalue
sangat penting dalam aljabar linear maupun
dalam informasi kuantum, dan kita akan punya banyak
hal lagi untuk dikatakan tentang mereka
seiring seri ini berlanjut.
Tapi untuk sekarang, kita hanya perlu
rumus sederhana ini.
Dan menggunakannya, kita bisa
menyederhanakan vektor state kita.
Dan itulah pada dasarnya fenomena phase
kickback yang ditulis sebagai rumus.
Ini berhasil karena state minus
adalah eigenvector dari operasi NOT yang memiliki
eigenvalue negatif satu.
Kita akan menggeneralisasi ini secara
cukup besar dalam Pelajaran 7, ketika kita beralih ke prosedur estimasi fase, yang merupakan penggerak
algoritma faktorisasi Shor.
Kita bisa melihat rumus ini bekerja dalam analisis algoritma Deutsch
sebagai berikut.
Sebelum query gate, state kita adalah produk tensor dari state minus dan plus.
Kemudian kita menerapkan query gate, dan mengekspansi
state plus memberikan kita state ini.
Kita sekarang menerapkan rumus phase kickback untuk mendapatkan ekspresi ini, dan kemudian analisisnya
berlanjut seperti sebelumnya.
Sama seperti sebelumnya, tapi di sini kita hanya menempatkan
fokus pada phase kickback sehingga kita bisa mengenalinya
dan kita juga bisa siap untuk
menghadapinya ketika muncul lagi.
Selanjutnya kita akan beralih ke
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, yang merupakan perluasan
dari algoritma Deutsch yang sebenarnya memecahkan beberapa
masalah query yang berbeda.
Keunggulan yang
diberikan algoritma Deutsch dibandingkan algoritma klasik
cukup sederhana, satu query versus dua.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa meningkatkan keunggulan itu agak lebih, dan saya akan menjelaskan apa yang saya maksud
ketika kita sampai di sana.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa bisa dilihat sebagai cara natural dan langsung untuk memperluas algoritma Deutsch
dari fungsi dari satu bit ke satu bit ke fungsi dari n bit ke satu bit, atau dengan kata lain, fungsi dengan bentuk ini.
Sebagai quantum circuit, algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa
terlihat seperti ini, dan saya akan menyebut ini sebagai Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
hanya untuk membuat
perbedaan kecil antara circuit ini dan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa itu sendiri karena ada juga
langkah post-processing klasik.
Idenya adalah bahwa jika kita menjalankan
circuit ini dan kemudian mengukur, kita akan mendapatkan beberapa string n bit y
yang memberitahu kita sesuatu
tentang fungsi f.
Pada titik ini, ngomong-ngomong, saya belum benar-benar menyebutkan
masalah query apa yang mungkin ingin kita
pecahkan dengan circuit ini, itu akan segera datang.
Tapi poinnya adalah bahwa
dengan menjalankan circuit ini, kita akan mendapatkan beberapa informasi tentang f yang berpotensi membantu
kita memecahkan masalah query
di mana f adalah inputnya. Dan seperti yang saya katakan sebentar lalu, kita sebenarnya bisa menggunakan circuit ini
untuk memecahkan beberapa
masalah query yang berbeda.
Pertama, mari kita lihat
masalah query yang dikenal sebagai masalah Deutsch-Jozsa, yang merupakan masalah yang
awalnya dimaksudkan untuk dipecahkan oleh Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
ini.
Masalah Deutsch-Jozsa adalah generalisasi dari masalah Deutsch, di mana tujuannya adalah menentukan apakah fungsi yang diberikan
adalah konstan atau seimbang.
Perhatikan bahwa ini bukan cara natural untuk menggeneralisasi masalah paritas
ke fungsi dengan bentuk ini.
Di sini kita tidak menghitung paritas, tugasnya adalah menghasilkan output 0 jika
fungsi f konstan
dan 1 jika fungsi f seimbang.
Hal pertama yang perlu diperhatikan tentang
masalah ini adalah bahwa ketika n, jumlah bit input ke
fungsi f, minimal 2,
ada pilihan untuk fungsi yang bukan konstan maupun seimbang.
Misalnya, berikut
fungsi dari 2 bit ke 1 bit yang bukan konstan maupun seimbang.
Ini bukan konstan karena kedua nilai biner
muncul di antara output, dan bukan seimbang
karena dua nilai output
muncul dengan frekuensi yang berbeda. 0 muncul tiga kali
dan 1 hanya muncul sekali.
Agar seimbang,
output 0 dan 1 harus terjadi dengan
jumlah yang persis sama.
Fakta bahwa ada fungsi yang bukan konstan maupun seimbang ketika n minimal 2 tidak apa-apa, kita hanya akan mempertimbangkan
fungsi seperti itu
sebagai input "don't care". Jadi dengan kata lain, ini
adalah masalah berjanji.
Dan berikut pernyataan tepat
dari masalah tersebut.
WEBVTT
Kita dijanjikan bahwa fungsi input f adalah konstan atau seimbang, dan tujuannya adalah mengetahui
mana yang mana.
Dan kita tidak bertanggung jawab atas apa yang terjadi jika input
tidak memenuhi janjinya.
Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa,
yang memecahkan masalah ini, pertama-tama menjalankan Deutsch-Jozsa circuit dan kemudian menghasilkan output 0
jika string yang kita
dapatkan dari pengukuran adalah string semua-nol
dan output 1 kalau tidak.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya adalah kita menghasilkan output OR dari
bit-bit yang kita ukur.
Untuk menganalisis algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, akan berguna untuk
mengambil beberapa momen untuk memikirkan gate Hadamard.
Tentu saja, kita bisa mendeskripsikan
operasi Hadamard sebagai matriks, tapi kita juga bisa mendeskripsikannya
dalam hal aksinya
pada state basis standar,
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dua persamaan ini bisa
digabungkan menjadi satu persamaan tunggal, yang mendeskripsikan bagaimana
operasi Hadamard bekerja untuk a yang merupakan salah satu dari
dua nilai biner,
dan kita bisa melangkah sedikit lebih jauh dan mengekspresikan apa yang kita
dapatkan sebagai jumlah seperti ini.
Menggunakan rumus itu, kita bisa mendapatkan rumus yang mendeskripsikan bagaimana lapisan
gate Hadamard bekerja, di mana kita menerapkan satu gate Hadamard
pada masing-masing dari n qubit.
Di sini kita mendeskripsikan
aksi ini pada state basis standar.
Dan untuk memperjelas notasinya, ketika kita menulis h tensor n seperti ini, di mana bagian tensor n adalah superscript,
yang kita maksud adalah produk tensor
n kali lipat dari H dengan dirinya sendiri, atau dengan kata lain, n salinan
h yang semuanya ditensor bersama.
Kita menerapkan operasi ini
ke state basis standar, dan di sini saya mengikuti
konvensi yang digunakan Qiskit
untuk mengindeks string biner, karena ini adalah waktu yang baik
untuk memperkenalkan konvensi tersebut.
Jadi x0 adalah bit, x1 adalah bit,
dan seterusnya dengan total n bit, dan bit-bit diurutkan
seperti yang kamu lihat di sini di layar.
Kamu bisa memikirkan
cara pengindeksan bit ini sebagai sesuai dengan signifikansinya jika kita melihat string sebagai
merepresentasikan bilangan bulat
dalam notasi biner, misalnya.
Jika kita menerapkan gate Hadamard
ke setiap qubit ini, kita bisa mengekspresikan hasilnya secara alternatif sebagai produk tensor n kali lipat
dari gate Hadamard yang diterapkan ke setiap qubit, dan kemudian kita bisa menerapkan rumus kita ke setiap faktor tensor.
Dan di sini kita menggunakan
nama y dan negatif 1 hingga y1 sebagai pengganti b dalam rumusnya,
jadi ini adalah nilai biner. Dan kita memastikan untuk menggunakan nama baru setiap kali kita menggunakan rumusnya.
Jika kita kemudian mengekspansi semuanya menggunakan multilinearitas
dari produk tensor, kita mendapatkan ekspresi
yang kamu lihat di sini.
Dan untuk memperjelas, n jumlah itu
digabungkan menjadi satu jumlah tunggal, tapi kita masih menjumlahkan
semua nilai yang mungkin
untuk nilai-nilai biner individual.
Sekarang mari kita rapikan agar kita bisa melangkah sedikit lebih jauh.
Dan langkah berikutnya adalah
memperkenalkan operasi baru pada string yang disebut binary dot product.
Ini adalah operasi pada string biner dengan panjang yang sama.
Dan binary dot product dari dua string x dan y
dengan panjang yang sama adalah eXclusive OR atau paritas
dari perkalian bit-bit individual.
Kamu juga bisa mengatakan bahwa itu adalah XOR dari AND logis dari bit-bit individual, karena AND adalah
hal yang sama dengan perkalian
untuk nilai biner. Cara lain untuk mendeskripsikannya adalah bahwa itu adalah 1 atau 0
tergantung pada apakah
jumlah dari perkalian bit-bit individual itu ganjil atau genap.
Ini sangat mirip seperti inner product jika kita menganggap string
sebagai vektor nilai biner, tapi di mana kita menghitung modulo-2,
atau dengan kata lain, kita mengambil sisanya setelah dibagi 2.
Ini bukan benar-benar inner product, jadi memang pantas mendapatkan nama yang berbeda.
Dalam kasus yang ada, kita bisa menggunakan binary dot
product untuk membuat rumus kita untuk aksi lapisan gate Hadamard
pada state basis standar lebih ringkas, dan inilah dia.
Kita menggunakan fakta bahwa
karena jumlah ini muncul di
eksponen negatif 1,
yang penting hanyalah apakah
itu genap atau ganjil, tapi selain itu, ini pada dasarnya hanyalah versi
yang dikompres dari rumus kita.
Ngomong-ngomong, binary
dot product bersifat simetris dalam arti x dot
y dan y dot x adalah sama,
jadi kita bebas untuk menukar
urutannya kapan pun itu berguna.
Dan sekarang setelah kita punya rumus itu, akan cukup mudah untuk menganalisis
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
Kita mulai dengan n qubit dalam state 0 dan qubit bawah dalam state 1, dan kita menjalankan gate Hadamard
pada semuanya.
Jadi inilah state dari
n + 1 qubit yang kita dapatkan.
Kita memperlakukan
qubit bawah secara terpisah karena itu akan lebih nyaman.
Dan sekali lagi, kita akan melihat fenomena phase
kickback terjadi.
WEBVTT
Kita bisa mendapatkan ekspresi ini
dengan menggunakan rumus kita, di mana kita mensubstitusikan string semua-nol untuk x dan mensubstitusikan x untuk y,
menyadari bahwa binary dot
product dari string semua-nol dengan string apa pun adalah 0.
Tapi kita juga bisa langsung mempertimbangkannya. Kita mengambil produk tensor dari n state plus, dan inilah yang kita dapatkan,
tensor ke state minus. Kemudian gate UF diterapkan, dan di sinilah fenomena phase
kickback terjadi.
Nilai f dari x di-XOR
ke state minus untuk setiap x dalam jumlah.
Jadi f dari x masuk ke dalam fase.
Kita sekarang menerapkan lapisan
gate Hadamard lain hanya ke n qubit teratas, dan kali ini, kita benar-benar
membutuhkan rumusnya.
Dan ketika kita menerapkannya dan melakukan sedikit
penyederhanaan, kita mendapatkan state ini.
Jadi itulah state akhir kita tepat
sebelum pengukuran.
State tersebut terlihat agak rumit, dan sulit untuk menyederhanakannya karena kita tidak tahu
apa pun tentang fungsi f.
Tapi ingat, yang benar-benar
perlu kita ketahui adalah apakah semua pengukuran menghasilkan outcome 0 atau tidak,
karena itulah yang menentukan jawaban kita untuk masalah tersebut.
Jika kita melihat bahwa setiap
outcome pengukuran adalah 0, kita menyimpulkan bahwa fungsinya konstan.
Dan jika salah satu dari
outcome pengukuran adalah 1, kita menyimpulkan bahwa fungsinya seimbang.
Jadi mari kita hitung probabilitas untuk mendapatkan string semua-nol
dari pengukuran.
Dan ternyata itu adalah satu hasil yang sebenarnya mudah untuk dihitung, karena binary dot
product dari string semua-nol
dengan string apa pun adalah nol. Jika kita memeriksa vektor kita dan
kita memikirkan apa yang terjadi ketika y adalah string semua-nol,
kita mendapatkan ekspresi ini
untuk probabilitas mendapatkan string semua-nol
dari pengukuran.
Dan mempertimbangkan dua kasus yang mungkin di mana f konstan dan f seimbang, kita melihat bahwa probabilitas untuk
mendapatkan string semua-nol adalah 1
dalam kasus f konstan, dan nol ketika f seimbang.
Ketika f konstan, jumlahnya adalah 2 pangkat
n atau negatif 2 pangkat n, dan dibagi dua pangkat n
dan diambil nilai absolutnya kuadrat menghasilkan 1.
Dan ketika f seimbang, jumlahnya sama dengan 0.
Itu karena kita akan mendapatkan
positif 1 dan negatif 1 dengan jumlah yang sama,
sehingga semuanya saling meniadakan.
Jadi begitulah. Algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa
memecahkan masalah Deutsch-Jozsa menggunakan satu query,
dan tidak ada error. Dengan asumsi semua operasi
dilakukan dengan sempurna, hasilnya benar setiap kali.
Jadi bagaimana perbandingannya dengan
apa yang bisa kita lakukan secara klasik?
Nah, jika kita mewajibkan
algoritma deterministik yang mendapatkan jawaban
benar setiap kali, maka dalam kasus terburuk,
kita membutuhkan 2 pangkat n dikurangi 1 plus 1 query, dan itu karena kita harus membuat query ke fungsi
pada lebih dari setengah inputnya untuk memastikan solusi.
Bahkan jika kita membuat query ke fungsi pada 2 pangkat n dikurangi 1
string input yang berbeda, mungkin saja kita akan
melihat nilai output yang sama
setiap saat, dan itu bisa karena
fungsinya konstan, atau bisa saja sebenarnya seimbang
dan kita sangat sial sudah melihat nilai output yang sama setiap saat.
Jadi itu adalah keunggulan besar
dari kuantum dibandingkan klasik, satu query versus
banyak query yang eksponensial.
Namun, jika kita menggunakan
algoritma query probabilistik dan kita menerima probabilitas kecil bahwa itu menjawab dengan salah,
maka kita sebenarnya hanya perlu beberapa query.
Khususnya, jika kita
secara acak memilih k string dan mengevaluasi fungsi
pada string-string acak tersebut,
maka kita cukup mungkin bisa mengetahui jawaban yang benar.
Secara khusus, kita menjawab 0 atau konstan ketika kita mendapatkan nilai fungsi yang sama setiap saat dan 1 atau seimbang
ketika kita melihat dua
nilai fungsi yang berbeda.
Jika kita melakukan itu, kita selalu benar ketika
fungsinya konstan karena tentu saja kita selalu akan melihat nilai output yang sama dalam kasus ini.
Dan jika f seimbang, kita sangat mungkin melihat
dua nilai output yang berbeda.
Kemungkinan kita tidak melihat
kedua nilai output dalam kasus ini sama dengan kemungkinan kita melempar koin k kali
dan mendapatkan hasil yang sama
setiap saat.
Jadi misalnya, jika kita
menetapkan k sama dengan 11, probabilitas mendapatkan jawaban yang salah kurang dari sepersepuluh persen.
Jadi terutama ketika kita mempertimbangkan fakta bahwa komputer kuantum tidak akan pernah sempurna dalam kenyataannya, kita sebenarnya tidak mendapatkan keunggulan yang
begitu besar di sini,
tapi kita sedang membuat kemajuan, dan kita memang punya keunggulan kuantum yang bisa dikuantifikasi dibandingkan klasik yang melampaui algoritma Deutsch.
Kita juga bisa menggunakan Deutsch-Jozsa circuit untuk memecahkan masalah query yang berbeda yang dikenal sebagai masalah Bernstein-Vazirani.
Berikut pernyataan masalah tersebut. Input adalah fungsi
dari n bit ke 1 bit, sama seperti masalah Deutsch-Jozsa,
WEBVTT
dan sekali lagi, ini adalah masalah berjanji.
Kali ini, janjinya adalah bahwa ada beberapa string n bit s yang membuat fungsi f
bekerja seperti yang kamu lihat di sini,
di mana output diberikan
oleh binary dot product dari input dengan string s ini,
dan tujuannya adalah cukup
menemukan string s. Jadi kita bisa membayangkan bahwa
string s tersembunyi dalam pengertian tertentu,
tapi kita bisa mempelajarinya
dengan membuat query ke f, dan tujuan kita adalah menemukan
string tersembunyi ini.
Untuk memperjelas, sebagian besar fungsi
tidak akan memenuhi janji ini, tapi seperti biasa, kita hanya peduli pada
fungsi input yang memenuhinya.
Ternyata, Deutsch-Jozsa circuit sebenarnya memecahkan masalah ini
langsung begitu saja.
Jika kita menjalankannya untuk
fungsi seperti yang kita punya di sini yang memenuhi
janji untuk beberapa string s, pengukuran akan mengungkapkan string s
tanpa memerlukan post-processing.
Jadi mari kita lihat bagaimana ini bekerja.
Kita sudah menganalisis
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, jadi kita sebenarnya bisa langsung
melompat ke bagian akhir.
Berikut ekspresi yang kita
miliki dari sebelumnya untuk state tepat sebelum pengukuran, dan ekspresi tersebut
valid untuk fungsi f apa pun.
Dan sekarang, jika kita mensubstitusikan
apa yang dijanjikan tentang fungsi f dan menyederhanakan,
kita mendapatkan state minus
untuk qubit bawah yang ditensor dengan ket s untuk n qubit teratas.
Dan jadi kita mendapatkan s ketika kita mengukur.
Ada beberapa pekerjaan yang harus dilakukan untuk melakukan penyederhanaan
yang telah saya tunjukkan di sini, dan saya tidak akan menjelaskannya dalam video ini,
tapi ada lebih banyak detail tentang itu dalam konten buku teks untuk seri ini, yang bisa kamu temukan dengan mengikuti tautan dalam deskripsi video,
atau coba sendiri saja
untuk latihan.
Jadi yang kita temukan adalah bahwa
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit memecahkan masalah Bernstein-Vazirani
dengan satu query.
Tidak terlalu sulit untuk menunjukkan
bahwa algoritma klasik apa pun, baik deterministik
maupun probabilistik, membutuhkan setidaknya n query
untuk memecahkan masalah Bernstein-Vazirani dengan alasan sederhana bahwa kita membutuhkan n bit
informasi untuk memulihkan s,
dan setiap query memberi kita paling banyak
1 bit informasi.
Jadi kita mendapatkan keunggulan lain dari kuantum dibandingkan algoritma query klasik, satu query untuk algoritma kuantum,
n query untuk algoritma klasik.
Perlu meluangkan sejenak untuk berbicara tentang
nomenklatur yang digunakan dalam konteks masalah ini dan sedikit tentang sejarahnya.
Orang-orang kadang menyebut algoritma yang baru saja saya deskripsikan sebagai algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani, tapi itu sebenarnya hanyalah
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit,
dan itu adalah sesuatu yang,
faktanya, sangat jelas dinyatakan dalam karya Bernstein dan Vazirani.
Jadi memang agak aneh bahwa itu disebut algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani karena pada dasarnya sama saja dengan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa
dikurangi post-processing. Bernstein dan Vazirani melangkah
selangkah lebih jauh.
Mereka mendefinisikan
versi rekursif dari masalah ini, di mana kamu pada dasarnya
harus memecahkan instansi masalah Bernstein-Vazirani
untuk membuka instansi baru dari masalah yang diatur dalam
pola seperti pohon yang rumit.
Ini adalah masalah yang sangat dibuat-buat, tapi poinnya adalah bahwa dengan
mendefinisikan masalah dengan cara ini, mereka bisa secara efektif meregangkan
pemisahan satu versus n query antara kuantum dan klasik.
Dan yang mereka dapatkan adalah
contoh pertama yang diketahui dari apa yang disebut keunggulan super-polynomial dari kuantum dibandingkan algoritma probabilistik.
Versi rekursif dari masalah
Bernstein-Vazirani ini juga belakangan terbukti sangat menarik dalam teori kompleksitas komputasional karena alasan yang berbeda.
Pokoknya, poinnya adalah bahwa
Bernstein dan Vazirani memang layak mendapatkan pengakuan atas kontribusi penting mereka,
tapi memang tidak
masuk akal untuk menyebut ini sebagai algoritma Bernstein-Vazirani, pada dasarnya ini hanyalah
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa.
Di bagian terakhir pelajaran ini, kita akan melihat satu
lagi algoritma query kuantum yang dikenal sebagai algoritma Simon.
Kamu akan melihat kesamaan yang jelas
antara algoritma ini dan algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa, tapi memang berbeda, dan yang lebih penting,
ini mengungkapkan keunggulan yang jauh lebih kuat dari kuantum dibandingkan algoritma query
klasik.
Secara khusus, ini memberikan kita
keunggulan eksponensial yang terbukti dari kuantum dibandingkan algoritma klasik, bahkan yang probabilistik.
Masalah yang dipecahkannya agak dibuat-buat, dan sulit untuk membayangkan situasi di mana memecahkan masalah ini
akan berguna,
tapi itu secara langsung menginspirasi
penemuan Peter Shor tentang algoritma kuantum
untuk faktorisasi bilangan bulat,
dan itu sangat mendukung
gagasan model query sebagai cawan Petri di mana ide-ide algoritmik kuantum dapat dikembangkan.
Mari kita mulai dengan masalah query yang dipecahkan oleh algoritma Simon, yang, seperti yang mungkin sudah kamu duga,
disebut masalah Simon.
Berikut pernyataan masalahnya, dan kita perlu menguraikannya untuk memahami apa yang dimaksudnya.
Hal pertama yang
perlu diperhatikan adalah bahwa kali ini, fungsi input f memetakan string n
bit ke string m bit
di mana m adalah bilangan bulat positif yang tidak selalu sama dengan satu.
WEBVTT
Ini adalah masalah berjanji. Dan seperti masalah Bernstein-Vazirani, janjinya melibatkan beberapa string s yang bisa kita anggap sebagai string tersembunyi,
dan juga seperti masalah
Bernstein-Vazirani, tujuannya adalah menghasilkan output
string tersembunyi s ini.
Namun janjinya lebih
rumit kali ini, jadi mari kita uraikan dan
pahami apa yang dikatakannya.
Untuk memulai, mari kita bacanya saja. Dikatakan bahwa ada sebuah string s dengan panjang sama dengan n
sedemikian sehingga kondisi "if"
dan "only if" tertentu berlaku untuk semua pilihan string n bit x dan y.
Secara khusus, harus
benar bahwa f dari x sama dengan f dari y jika dan hanya jika salah satu dari
dua kemungkinan berlaku.
Kemungkinan pertama adalah x sama dengan y, dan kemungkinan kedua adalah bahwa dengan mengambil eXclusive OR bitwise dari x
dengan string tersembunyi s, kita mendapatkan Y.
Ini ternyata adalah
janji yang cukup ketat dalam arti sebagian besar
fungsi tidak akan memenuhinya.
Hanya fungsi yang sangat khusus
yang memenuhi kondisi ini.
Nah, untuk mendapatkan pemahaman yang lebih baik tentang janji ini dan karenanya tentang masalah itu sendiri, kita akan mempertimbangkan dua kasus utama.
Kasus pertama adalah bahwa s
adalah string semua-nol.
Dalam kasus ini, kita bisa menyederhanakan pernyataan "if"
dan "only if" dalam janjinya karena eXclusive OR bitwise dari string x apa pun
dengan string semua-nol
adalah string x itu sendiri.
Jadi kondisinya disederhanakan
menjadi f dari x sama dengan f dari y jika dan hanya jika x sama dengan y.
Dan itu hanya cara lain untuk mengatakan bahwa f adalah fungsi satu-ke-satu.
Dengan kata lain, string f dari x harus unik
untuk setiap string x yang mungkin.
Jadi jika f adalah fungsi satu-ke-satu, maka janjinya memang dipenuhi, khususnya untuk s yang merupakan
string semua-nol,
dan dalam kasus ini, itulah
output yang benar.
Kasus kedua adalah bahwa s
bukan string semua-nol, dan yang ini mengimplikasikan bahwa fungsi f harus dua-ke-satu.
Jadi untuk setiap string input x, ada tepat satu string lain yang dipetakan f ke string
yang sama dengan yang dipetakan x,
dan terlebih lagi, string yang lain itu
harus berupa string yang kita dapatkan dengan mengambil
eXclusive OR bitwise dari x dengan s.
Cara lain untuk mengatakannya
adalah bahwa setiap string n bit x punya pasangan, dan pasangan itu adalah string yang kita dapatkan
dengan mengambil eXclusive OR bitwise dengan s.
Dua pasangan apa pun harus memberikan
kita string output yang sama jika kita memasukkannya ke f, dan tidak ada string lain yang diizinkan untuk memberikan kita
string output yang sama itu.
Jadi ini adalah string-string yang berbeda yang dihasilkan pasangan-pasangan.
Berikut contoh fungsi seperti ini yang dideskripsikan berdasarkan tabel nilainya.
Jadi ini adalah fungsi
dari 3 bit ke 5 bit.
Jika kita menatap tabel
nilai ini sebentar, kita menemukan bahwa janjinya
terpenuhi untuk string 011.
000 dan 011 adalah pasangan. Meng-XOR salah satunya
dengan s memberikan kita yang lainnya,
dan keduanya mengambil nilai output yang sama, yaitu 10011 dalam kasus khusus ini, dan tidak ada string lain yang menghasilkan
string output yang sama itu.
001 dan 010 adalah pasangan karena meng-XOR salah satunya
dengan s memberikan yang lainnya, dan keduanya menghasilkan nilai output yang sama,
yang sekali lagi, tidak dihasilkan
oleh string lain mana pun.
Dan situasinya
serupa untuk 100 dan 111 serta 101 dan 110.
Jadi jika input ke
masalah adalah fungsi ini, jawaban yang benar adalah string 011.
Seperti yang saya katakan sebelumnya, sebagian besar fungsi tidak memenuhi janji ini, ini adalah kondisi yang sangat spesifik.
Perlu juga diperhatikan bahwa
jika janjinya terpenuhi, itu hanya bisa dipenuhi untuk satu string s.
Jadi selalu hanya ada satu
jawaban yang benar untuk masalah ini.
Jadi itulah masalah Simon. Seperti yang saya katakan, sulit untuk membayangkan situasi praktis di mana kamu ingin memecahkan masalah ini,
tapi itu bukan poinnya. Poinnya adalah mencoba mencari tahu apa yang kuantum itu bagus, dan ternyata jauh lebih unggul
dari algoritma klasik untuk
memecahkan masalah khusus ini.
Sekarang mari kita lihat
algoritma Simon, yang memecahkan masalah Simon.
Algoritma ini terdiri dari
menjalankan quantum circuit yang kamu lihat di sini beberapa kali, diikuti dengan langkah
post-processing klasik,
dan kita akan lebih spesifik tentang apa yang dimaksud beberapa
kali itu nanti.
Circuit tersebut sangat mirip
dengan Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, kali ini karena fungsi
f memetakan n bit ke m bit,
query gate-nya berbeda. Alih-alih hanya satu
qubit di bawah, kita sekarang punya m qubit di bawah
dan n di atas seperti sebelumnya.
Perbedaan utamanya adalah bahwa kita tidak
menyiapkan state minus atau beberapa state minus di bawah.
Semua qubit bawah ini
diinisialisasi ke state 0, dan state-state tersebut langsung
masuk ke query gate.
WEBVTT
Jadi tidak akan ada phase kickback yang terlibat dalam algoritma ini, memang bukan begitu cara kerja yang satu ini.
Selain perbedaan-perbedaan
yang baru saja saya sebutkan, tampilannya sangat mirip dengan
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
Kita menerapkan lapisan gate Hadamard, kemudian kita menerapkan query gate satu kali, dan kemudian kita menerapkan lapisan gate Hadamard lain
diikuti dengan pengukuran basis standar dari n qubit teratas.
Idenya adalah bahwa setiap kali kita
menjalankan circuit ini dan mengukur, kita akan mendapatkan beberapa string y yang memberitahu kita sesuatu
tentang string tersembunyi s
dalam masalah Simon. Dan dengan menjalankan circuit
beberapa kali secara independen, kita akan mengumpulkan cukup
bukti statistik tentang s
untuk dapat mengetahui apa itu
dengan keyakinan yang tinggi.
Sekarang mari kita analisis quantum
circuit untuk algoritma Simon untuk melihat apa yang dilakukannya.
State setelah lapisan pertama
gate Hadamard terlihat seperti ini, mirip dengan yang kita punya untuk
algoritma Deutsch-Jozsa.
Kecuali kali ini, m qubit bawah semuanya dalam state 0
alih-alih dalam state minus.
Setelah query gate dilakukan, kita melihat bahwa nilai f dari x telah ditulis ke
m qubit bawah atau paling kiri,
dan itu karena f dari x telah di-XOR ke string semua-nol.
Jadi sekali lagi, tidak ada phase kickback yang terjadi dalam algoritma ini.
Kita kemudian menjalankan lapisan kedua
gate Hadamard.
Dan menggunakan rumus yang sama seperti sebelumnya untuk aksi
lapisan gate Hadamard pada state basis standar, ket x dalam kasus ini,
seperti dalam rumus aslinya, kita mendapatkan state ini, di mana aksi gate Hadamard
telah dibuat lebih jelas. Tapi kalau mau, kita juga bisa menulis state
dalam bentuk yang lebih kompak seperti yang kita punya di sini.
Pada titik ini, kita mengukur n qubit teratas untuk mendapatkan beberapa string n bit y, dan kita hanya perlu mencari tahu
berapa probabilitasnya
untuk string-string yang berbeda. Dan itu akan membantu kita memahami
informasi apa yang kita dapatkan dari string y ini tentang string s
yang tersembunyi di dalam fungsi f.
Kita akan membutuhkan
lebih banyak ruang untuk ini, dan kita benar-benar tidak membutuhkan
diagram circuit lagi, jadi mari kita singkirkan dan berikan diri kita lebih
banyak ruang untuk analisis.
Berikut state tepat
sebelum pengukuran, yang merupakan pengukuran basis standar dari n qubit teratas atau paling kanan.
Jadi pengukurannya
sesuai dengan ket kedua.
Mari kita notasikan dengan p dari y, probabilitas bahwa pengukurannya memberi kita string y untuk setiap y yang mungkin.
Dan jika kita mengikuti aturan dari Pelajaran 2, kita mendapatkan bahwa setiap probabilitas ini adalah norma Euclidean dikuadratkan dari vektor apa pun yang ditensor
ke state basis standar,
yang sesuai dengan y dalam
vektor state kuantum kita.
Itu memberi kita ekspresi ini.
Nah, untuk mendapatkan gambaran yang lebih baik
tentang probabilitas-probabilitas ini, kita perlu menggunakan beberapa notasi, dan kamu mungkin sudah
familiar dengan notasi ini
karena cukup umum dalam matematika.
Pertama, ketika kita merujuk pada
range dari fungsi f, kita hanya berarti himpunan semua string yang bisa keluar dari fungsi ini.
Jadi itu adalah himpunan semua f dari x yang mencakup semua
pilihan yang mungkin dari string input x.
Kedua, kita akan menggunakan notasi ini yang kamu lihat di sini untuk berarti himpunan semua string input x
yang f petakan ke string z yang diberikan, untuk pilihan
z apa pun yang ingin kita pertimbangkan.
Ini sedikit terlihat seperti
invers dari fungsi f, tapi ini bukan benar-benar invers karena f tidak harus invertible.
Kita juga melihat bahwa kita punya
sebuah himpunan sebagai argumen di sisi kiri, dan dalam kasus ini, itu adalah himpunan yang hanya berisi
satu string z,
dan itulah petunjuk yang kita butuhkan untuk menyadari bahwa kita tidak berbicara tentang
invers dari fungsi f, ini disebut pre-image.
Pre-image bisa
didefinisikan lebih umum untuk himpunan apa pun yang diberikan sebagai argumen, bukan hanya himpunan yang berisi
satu elemen,
tapi ini semua yang kita butuhkan. Ini bukan notasi terbaik di dunia karena mudah
dikacaukan dengan invers,
tapi cukup jelas
dan banyak digunakan, jadi kita akan pakailah.
Dan sekarang jika kita menggunakan notasi ini, kita bisa menulis ulang vektor yang kita ambil norma Euclidean dikuadratkan untuk mendapatkan probabilitas mengukur setiap string y.
Kita melakukan ini karena kita perlu melihat
apa koefisiennya untuk setiap state basis standar individual, dan itu tidak jelas dari
ekspresi ini,
karena, pada umumnya, kita mungkin
memiliki beberapa pilihan x yang memberikan kita string f dari x yang sama.
Pada dasarnya, yang kita lakukan
adalah memecah jumlah atas x dengan pertama menjumlahkan semua
z dalam range dari f,
dan kemudian di dalam jumlah itu, menjumlahkan semua x dalam pre-image dari z, atau lebih tepatnya,
pre-image dari himpunan
yang berisi string z.
Itu memungkinkan kita menggantikan f dari x dengan z di dalam ket di sini.
Dan jumlah keseluruhan, string-string x berbeda yang dipetakan f ke setiap z dikumpulkan ke dalam
koefisien untuk setiap ket.
Kita pada dasarnya menempatkan string ke dalam keranjang, menjumlahkan keranjang-keranjang itu, dan kemudian menjumlahkan
string dalam setiap keranjang,
WEBVTT
tapi itu setara dengan hanya
menjumlahkan semua string.
Jadi kita memang mendapatkan ekspresi yang setara dengan
yang kita mulai,
dan sekarang kita bisa menghitung
norma Euclidean dikuadratkan.
Itu hanyalah jumlah dari kuadrat nilai absolut
dari koefisien-koefisien, dan jadi kita mendapatkan ekspresi ini
untuk probabilitas kita.
Tentu saja, beri dirimu
waktu untuk memverifikasi ini, jika kamu memilih untuk melakukannya, perlu waktu untuk terbiasa dengan semua ini
dan untuk bisa melakukan
perhitungan-perhitungan ini, dan semakin banyak latihan yang kamu berikan pada dirimu, semakin mudah jadinya.
Sejauh ini, kita sebenarnya belum
menggunakan janji dalam masalah Simon sama sekali.
Analisis kita tentang probabilitas-probabilitas ini sebenarnya berlaku untuk fungsi f apa pun, tapi sekarang saatnya untuk memikirkan masalah Simon
secara khusus.
Kita akan memecahnya menjadi dua kasus yang sama
yang kita miliki sebelumnya.
Kasus pertama adalah bahwa s
adalah string semua-nol, dan kasus kedua adalah bahwa
s bukan string semua-nol.
Dalam kasus pertama, bahwa
s adalah string semua-nol, hal-hal cukup sederhana.
Dalam kasus ini, seperti yang kita lihat sebelumnya, kita memiliki bahwa f adalah fungsi satu-ke-satu, jadi ada satu string x
yang dipetakan ke setiap
string z dalam range dari f.
Itu membuat nilai absolut dikuadratkan dari jumlah atas string-string tersebut sama dengan 1 karena hanya ada satu
suku dalam jumlah,
itu adalah plus 1 atau minus 1, tapi tidak masalah yang mana karena kita mengambil
nilai absolut dikuadratkan, dan jadi kita mendapatkan satu.
Ada 2 pangkat n
elemen dalam range dari f, dan kita tahu itu karena f satu-ke-satu, jadi ada satu string dalam
range untuk setiap string input.
Dan jika kita mengevaluasi seluruh ekspresi, kita menemukan bahwa setiap string y muncul dengan probabilitas
satu dibagi dua pangkat n.
Jadi dengan kata lain,
pengukuran memberikan kita string y yang dipilih secara seragam secara acak.
Itu mungkin tidak terlihat terlalu berguna, tapi kita akan, faktanya, bisa
membedakan perilaku ini dari perilaku yang kita dapatkan dalam kasus
bahwa s bukan string semua-nol, dan kita akan melihat bagaimana itu berjalan sebentar lagi.
Untuk sekarang, kita cukup mengamati bahwa jika
f memenuhi janji dalam masalah Simon dalam kasus di mana s adalah string semua-nol,
maka hasil pengukurannya adalah string acak yang seragam.
Sekarang mari kita beralih ke kasus kedua, yaitu bahwa janjinya
terpenuhi untuk string s yang bukan string semua-nol.
Dalam kasus ini, seperti yang kita bahas sebelumnya, setiap string z dalam range dari f memiliki tepat dua string yang dipetakan ke dalamnya,
karena setiap string punya pasangan, dan setiap pasangan
dipetakan ke beberapa string unik, dan secara khusus, setiap pasangan string
adalah string yang kita dapatkan dengan meng-XOR dengan s.
Jadi jika kita memilih string z apa pun
dalam range dari f, dan kita menamai w untuk salah satu dari
string yang dipetakan f ke z,
maka XOR dari w dengan s adalah
string lain yang dipetakan ke z.
Melihat hanya satu suku dalam jumlah kita yang sesuai dengan string z apa pun dalam range yang kita pikirkan,
kita melihat bahwa kita bisa
menulisnya lebih eksplisit seperti yang kita punya di sini.
Kita punya dua string dalam pre-image dari z, w dan w di-XOR dengan s.
Jadi kita bisa menulis jumlah
seperti yang kamu lihat di layar, dan sekarang yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menarik keluar faktor
negatif 1 pangkat w.y.
Faktor itu akan menjadi
plus 1 atau minus 1, jadi ia hilang ketika kita
mengambil nilai absolut,
dan apa yang tersisa adalah
ekspresi ini.
Detailnya tidak semuanya ditampilkan di sini, dan tidak harus jelas bahwa itu bekerja seperti ini, tapi kamu bisa memeriksa bahwa dua ekspresi ini sama
dengan kembali ke definisi
dari binary dot product dan memikirkan apa yang terjadi ketika hal-hal ini berada dalam
eksponen negatif 1,
tidak berbeda dengan yang kita punya untuk
masalah Bernstein-Vazirani.
Akhirnya, kita bisa memecah ekspresi ini
menjadi dua kasus.
Nilainya 4 ketika binary dot
product dari s dan y adalah 0, dan nilainya 0 ketika binary
dot product dari s dan y adalah 1.
Perhatikan khususnya bahwa
tidak ada ketergantungan sama sekali di sini pada w atau z, ini hanya bergantung pada s dan y.
Alasan ini terjadi adalah
karena sifat janji yang sangat spesifik dan khusus.
Pada dasarnya, inilah mengapa janji itu dirumuskan dengan cara ini, agar semuanya berhasil seperti ini.
Sekali lagi, setiap string punya pasangan, yang kita dapatkan dengan meng-XOR dengan
satu string tersembunyi s ini,
dan itulah yang membuat semua ini terjadi.
Sekarang kita bisa kembali ke
ekspresi untuk probabilitas dan memasukkan nilai-nilainya.
Ketika s bukan string semua-nol, ada 2 pangkat n dikurangi 1
elemen dalam range dari f,
yang merupakan separuh dari
jumlah string input, dan memasukkan nilai-nilai yang baru saja kita hitung memberikan rumus ini.
Jadi kali ini, y bukan
string yang sepenuhnya acak, melainkan y seragam atas tepat setengah dari string n bit,
WEBVTT
dan secara khusus, seragam
atas string-string yang memiliki binary dot
product sama dengan 0 dengan s.
Sekarang setelah kita tahu bagaimana circuit
untuk algoritma Simon bekerja dan secara khusus berapa
probabilitas untuk berbagai outcome pengukuran,
masih tersisa untuk menjelaskan bagaimana ini membantu kita memecahkan masalah Simon.
Meringkas apa yang baru saja kita pelajari, jika kasusnya adalah bahwa fungsi f memenuhi janji dalam masalah Simon,
ketika string tersembunyi s
adalah string semua-nol, kita mendapatkan string yang sepenuhnya acak dari pengukuran,
di mana setiap string n bit
y sama-sama mungkin.
Jika di sisi lain, fungsi f memenuhi janji untuk string s yang berbeda, satu yang tidak sama
dengan string semua-nol,
maka kita mendapatkan string acak y yang memiliki binary dot product
sama dengan 0 dengan s, dan di antara semua string tersebut,
setiap y sama-sama mungkin.
Tapi kita tidak akan pernah mendapatkan string y yang memiliki binary dot product
sama dengan 1 dengan s.
Pertanyaannya menjadi, "Apakah informasi ini cukup
untuk menentukan s?" Dan jawabannya, seperti yang sudah saya sarankan, adalah ya,
asalkan kita menjalankan
circuit cukup banyak kali.
Secara khusus, mari kita asumsikan
bahwa kita menjalankan circuit k kali, di mana K sama dengan n plus r,
di mana r adalah suatu angka yang akan
mengontrol kemungkinan bahwa kita berhasil memulihkan s.
Hanya sebagai contoh, jika
kita memilih r sama dengan 10, kita akan berhasil dengan
probabilitas lebih besar dari 99,9%,
jadi kita tidak perlu r yang terlalu besar.
Pada umumnya, probabilitas gagal kurang dari probabilitas
melempar koin adil r kali dan mendapatkan kepala setiap saat.
Jadi jika 99,9% belum cukup
baik, ambil r sama dengan 20, dan peluang gagalnya kurang dari satu banding satu juta,
atau pilih r apa pun yang
bikin kamu nyaman. Kamu tidak bisa menjamin solusi yang benar, tapi kamu bisa membuat
probabilitas error bisa diabaikan
untuk semua maksud dan tujuan.
Di sini kita menamai
string-string ini y1 sampai yk, di mana kita menggunakan superscript untuk membantu kita menamai string-string ini,
hanya agar kita bisa menyimpan subscript untuk merujuk pada bit-bit individual
dari string-string tersebut.
Jadi ini bukan eksponen
atau semacamnya, ini hanyalah nama yang kita berikan untuk k string ini.
Masing-masing memiliki panjang n karena kita mendapatkannya
dari menjalankan circuit untuk algoritma Simon.
Jadi kita bisa menuliskan
bit-bit individual dari k string ini seperti yang kamu lihat di sini.
Yang sekarang kita lakukan adalah membuat matriks m, di mana setiap entri dari matriks ini adalah bit, dan kita mendapatkan bit-bit ini dari string-string
yang baru saja kita ukur, seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Jadi matriks ini memiliki k baris dan n kolom, dan entrinya semua adalah nilai biner.
Sekarang, kita tidak tahu apa itu s. Itulah yang sedang kita cari, tapi bayangkan sejenak bahwa kita memang tahu s,
dan kita membentuk vektor kolom
dari bit-bit s, seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini.
Jika kita mengalikan vektor itu dengan m dan kemudian mengambil hasilnya modulo-2, atau cara lain untuk mengatakannya
adalah bahwa kita menggantikan penjumlahan
dengan eXclusive OR, maka kita pasti
mendapatkan vektor semua-nol.
Itu karena setiap
entri dalam vektor yang dihasilkan ini tidak lain adalah binary dot product dari s
dengan salah satu baris dari m.
Jika S kebetulan adalah string semua-nol, kita selalu akan mendapatkan vektor nol dari binary dot product.
Dan jika s bukan string semua-nol, kita akan mendapatkan ini dari apa yang
kita ketahui tentang probabilitas untuk string y1 hingga yk muncul.
Khususnya, binary dot product
dengan s selalu nol untuk semua string ini.
Cara sederhana untuk mengatakannya adalah bahwa vektor ini
yang dibentuk dari bit-bit s selalu berada dalam null
space dari matriks m,
dengan asumsi kita melakukan semua
aritmetika kita modulo-2, tapi tentu saja, kita tidak tahu apa itu s,
kita sedang mencoba menemukan s.
Tapi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah menghitung
null space dari matriks m ini, sekali lagi, modulo-2.
Secara khusus, kita bisa melakukan itu menggunakan teknik
eliminasi Gaussian, yang merupakan prosedur yang sering diajarkan
dalam kursus aljabar linear pengantar.
Ini bekerja dengan sangat baik ketika kita melakukan semua aritmetika modulo-2, dan bisa dilakukan dengan cukup
efisien dengan komputer.
Dan jika kita menghitung null space dari m, mengingat cara spesifik string k ini
telah dipilih secara acak,
kita akan dapat memulihkan s dengan probabilitas lebih besar dari
1 dikurangi 2 pangkat negatif r.
Untuk lebih spesifik, apa yang akan kita lihat dengan probabilitas lebih besar dari
1 dikurangi 2 pangkat negatif r adalah bahwa null space
mencakup vektor semua-nol,
seperti yang selalu dilakukan untuk setiap matriks, serta vektor yang sesuai dengan s, baik itu vektor semua-nol atau tidak.
Dan yang terpenting, tidak ada vektor lain yang akan
muncul dalam null space.
Sebenarnya tidak terlalu sulit untuk membuktikan ini, meski saya tidak akan membahasnya secara detail.
WEBVTT
Idenya adalah bahwa jika kita
punya beberapa string lain yang bukan vektor semua-nol
dan bukan s, maka setiap string acak, y1 hingga yk,
pada dasarnya akan menyingkirkannya
dari null space dengan probabilitas seperdua.
Jadi setelah k shot, ia
tidak mungkin untuk bertahan, dan faktanya, tidak ada
string yang tidak seharusnya ada
yang kemungkinan besar akan bertahan. Dan fakta yang sangat sederhana
dari teori probabilitas, yang dikenal sebagai union bound, bisa
digunakan untuk menetapkan itu.
Saya belum menjelaskan semua
detailnya di sini, tapi mudah-mudahan, kamu mengerti ide bahwa dengan menghitung null
space modulo-2 dari matriks m ini,
kita sangat mungkin untuk memulihkan s, dan begitulah cara algoritma Simon
memecahkan masalah Simon.
Masih ada satu hal yang tersisa
untuk dikatakan tentang masalah Simon, dan itu berkaitan dengan
kesulitan klasik dari masalah ini,
yaitu, berapa banyak query yang dibutuhkan algoritma query klasik untuk memecahkan masalah Simon?
Jawabannya adalah, banyak, pada umumnya.
Ada pernyataan-pernyataan tepat yang berbeda
yang bisa dibuat tentang kesulitan klasik dari masalah ini, dan berikut hanya salah satunya.
Jika kita punya algoritma query
probabilistik apa pun dan algoritma tersebut membuat lebih sedikit dari 2 pangkat n dibagi 2
dikurangi 1, dikurangi 1 query,
jadi itu adalah jumlah query
yang eksponensial dalam n, maka algoritma tersebut akan gagal
memecahkan masalah Simon,
dengan probabilitas setidaknya seperdua.
Kadang-kadang, membuktikan
hasil ketidakmungkinan seperti ini bisa sangat menantang, tapi yang ini tidak terlalu sulit untuk dibuktikan
melalui analisis probabilistik
yang mendasar.
Saya tidak akan melakukan itu dalam pelajaran video ini, dan saya hanya akan fokus
pada intuisi di baliknya.
Kita sedang mencoba menemukan string tersembunyi s, tapi selama kita tidak membuat query ke fungsi pada dua string yang memiliki
nilai output yang sama,
kita akan mendapatkan informasi yang sangat terbatas
tentang s.
Pada dasarnya, yang kita pelajari adalah
bahwa string tersembunyi s bukan eXclusive OR dari dua string berbeda apa pun
yang telah kita query,
Dan jika kita membuat query ke fungsi pada lebih sedikit dari jumlah query ini, masih akan ada banyak pilihan s
yang belum dikesampingkan.
Ini bukan bukti formal,
tapi itulah ide dasarnya.
Jadi sebagai ringkasan, algoritma Simon memberikan kita keunggulan yang mencolok dari kuantum dibandingkan algoritma
klasik dalam model query.
Khususnya, algoritma Simon
memecahkan masalah Simon dengan jumlah query yang linier dalam jumlah bit input
n ke fungsi kita,
sedangkan algoritma klasik mana pun,
bahkan yang probabilistik, perlu membuat jumlah
query yang eksponensial dalam n
untuk memecahkan masalah Simon dengan probabilitas sukses yang wajar.
Memang benar bahwa masalah Simon adalah masalah yang agak buatan yang mungkin tidak benar-benar ingin dipecahkan oleh siapa pun,
tapi itu sekunder. Kadang ide-ide perlu dikembangkan sebelum diterapkan.
Dan memang, Peter Shor telah dengan jelas menyatakan bahwa algoritma Simonlah yang menginspirasi algoritma kuantumnya yang sekarang terkenal
untuk faktorisasi bilangan bulat, yang akan kita lihat dalam beberapa pelajaran lagi.
Dan itulah akhir dari Pelajaran 5.
Dalam pelajaran ini, kita telah melihat model
query dari komputasi, dan kita telah melihat perkembangan contoh-contoh
algoritma kuantum
yang menunjukkan keunggulan dibandingkan algoritma klasik
dalam model ini.
Memang, sebenarnya ada banyak lagi
yang diketahui tentang model query dan algoritma kuantum untuk masalah lain yang
belum saya bahas.
Jadi kalau kamu merasa model ini
menarik, masih ada banyak lagi
yang bisa dipelajari tentangnya.
Langkah kita berikutnya adalah meninggalkan
model query dan beralih ke model komputasi
yang lebih representatif
dari jenis masalah yang mungkin kita harapkan untuk dipecahkan dalam praktik.
Saya harap kamu mau bergabung dengan saya untuk Pelajaran 6, di mana kita akan fokus terutama pada
meletakkan fondasi untuk mempelajari algoritma kuantum.
Dan dari sana, kita akan beralih ke beberapa
algoritma kuantum yang spesifik, termasuk algoritma Shor
untuk faktorisasi bilangan bulat
di pelajaran-pelajaran selanjutnya. Sampai jumpa!